[Music]
firstly to make it clear in the
disagreement I agree with of course I
think everyone knows who I agree with
but um I do because you know what it is
though you know what's actually funny
the things that she's saying are common
knowledge 20 30 years ago this is how
the world functions this is how the
whole world function the things I say
that somehow people believe are
controversial are exactly the way the
world function in like the 90s the AES
the 70s all of this entire period of
human history men had a role of
masculine Aid women had a role of
femininity we worked as a team now the
world's come along and they've destroyed
and broken everything and there's this
new Progressive thing in this new
generation of women who seem to believe
that if we completely [__] it all off
it's going to end up better